[Música]
cuándo fue la última vez que tuvieron
una crisis fue hoy algunas horas algunos
días algunos meses quizás algunos de
ustedes está tenido una crisis en este
momento
pero cuando fue la última vez que
disfrutaron de una crisis que la
sintieron que la vivieron e inclusive
estuvieron agradecidos por tenerla es
una pregunta difícil verdad y es que
quien disfruta las crisis pero qué
pasaría se les diría que porque
pudiésemos cambiar esos momentos de
crisis en obras de arte en verdaderas
obras de arte les dejo la idea en la
cabeza
cuando tenía cero horas cero minutos y
algunos segundos en esta vida comencé a
presenciar sin darme cuenta una de las
mayores crisis que impactaron mi vida
hasta el día de hoy
y es que mi llegada a este mundo
desencadenó el edificio de arresto
desencadenó una enfermedad autoinmune y
en una de las personas más importantes
para mí en este mundo mi madre
durante los últimos 32 años bien y madre
sufrir con las crisis gracias a una
enfermedad que no le permitió cargarme
en brazos que quizá le costó mil veces
más esfuerzo que cualquier otra persona
él tiene una vida normal y que durante
32 años no le permitió estar un solo día
sin dolor
pero decidió que esto me impactó no sólo
fue por ver la cantidad de sufrimiento
que una sola persona puede soportar sino
por ver que a pesar de todos estos
momentos de angustia de dolor y de
crisis hoy mi madre es una mujer exitosa
de hecho es la mujer más fuerte que
conozco y de hecho está acá en esta
audiencia siempre con una sonrisa y con
la mejor actitud
pero si yo les cuento esto
es por qué
cuando armaba esta charla me proponía
contar estas estas pequeñas crisis que
tuve a lo largo de mi vida de
emprendedor
estos estos momentos de angustia
parecían ser realmente nada con lo que
tienen que vivir muchísimas personas
cada día pero también me di cuenta que
estas crisis duelen e incomodan igual
que no hay tal cosa como demasiado
pequeñas pero tampoco las existen
demasiado grandes y que sean del tamaño
que sean no está mal todas las crisis
donde igual y no está mal sentirnos mal
pero lo que sucede después y lo que
hacemos con ellas depende de cada uno
hace 12 años decidí tomar uno de los
caminos más inciertos atemorizantes
ingratos y llenos de crisis el ser un
emprendedor y es que hace ese aire de
aventura de crear de impactar y de
construir las cosas y de pensar que
podemos cambiar del mundo a nuestro
estilo era y es algo demasiado adictivo
y volviendo un poco más atrás yo
recuerdo que a mis 17 años salía de uno
de los colegios más prestigiosos de mi
ciudad famoso por crear grandes
ingenieros intelectuales e inclusive
presidentes en mi mente yo tenía la idea
y el camino estructurado de seguir una
vida y un camión estructurado de hecho
recuerdo que había sido aceptado por una
universidad en chile a la cual tenía
muchísimas ganas de ir y de ser un
ingeniero de maestrías y todo eso y
sentía que
y sentía que mi camino estructurados
hacia en realidad de hecho ya había sido
aceptado en nuestra universidad en chile
y sentía que sus sueños de enero
adolescentes y me hacían realidad pero
como el mundo da vueltas y es que
siempre lo hace
este mi mundo estructurado casi se cae
cuando por diferentes motivos tuve que
quedarme estudiar localmente y entré en
crisis pero se dan cuenta del tamaño de
la crisis de ese momento de hecho me da
vergüenza hablar de esa crisis está
estando para acá pero me dolía igual era
una crisis igual y en medio de toda esa
crisis me puse a pensar cuáles eran las
cosas que había perdido al no salir
estudiar fuera pero también me puse
analizar cuáles eran esas cosas las
cuales solamente yo podía tomar una
decisión en las cuales mis decisiones
podían
que cambiar el curso de mi historia
y decide emprender y esa y esta decisión
de hecho trajo una recompensa bastante
pronto la de encontrar a un amigo ya mi
socio una persona tan loca como yo con
quien compartimos de hecho esas ganas
ideas locas de cambiar el mundo y con
quién hacemos negocios hasta hoy
de hecho recuerdo que nuestra primera
gran idea que tuvimos como emprendedores
hace 11 años fue hacer cinturones y
cinturones de tela y de verdad quién
piensa hacer cinturón de tela como
primer negocio pero bueno
no teníamos idea de nada solo queríamos
crear y construir y no se hubieran visto
a los dos días y días cosiendo metros y
metros de cinta puliendo queda de villa
que sacábamos y cuidando la calidad de
cada cinturón que sacábamos yo en mi
vida había agarrado una aguja pero
estábamos ahí construyendo nuestro
imperio
obviamente este negocio no fue a ningún
lado era malísimo y de hecho tenemos
cientos y cientos de cinturones
guardados en la misma un cajón
pero lo que más aprendí de esta primera
etapa y de estas primeras crisis fueron
dos cosas uno que muchas veces crisis
significa tomar decisiones y que si esas
decisiones las hacemos con la que tener
con lo que tenemos dentro llama la
intuición corazón sexto sentido o lo que
sean esas decisiones realmente pueden
cambiar la vida 2 y si no creen que lo
que están haciendo puede ser realmente
grande entonces su decisión o no fue tan
buena o no lo hicieron con el corazón y
les aseguro que en ese momento están
encendiendo la mecha para una crisis
todavía mayor
luego un tiempo y ya habíamos descartado
la idea de ser emprendedores textiles y
pues nos dedicamos a hacer negocios o
empresa en algo que de alguna manera
entendíamos
y algo en lo que nos gustaba la
tecnología
en ese punto ya habíamos fundado nuestra
primera empresa que hará un estudio web
bastante tradicional que de hecho lo
fundamos con los 150 dólares de nuestro
primer cliente luego cerramos esta
empresa para fundar la segunda empresa
que era un negocio en la plataforma
directamente basada en internet donde
aparentemente íbamos encaminados al
éxito y aparentemente la empresa tenía
mucho potencial financiero de hecho
recuerdo que entre algunos de los socios
decidimos mudarnos a francisco a
california y vivíamos en pleno centro en
pleno corazón de silicon valley vivíamos
a sólo dos cuadras de paypal e íbamos a
los bares de stanford nos rodeamos de
gente de google interactuado nos cada
día con gente que construía cosas
increíbles y a pesar de que todos los
días
cogíamos chili con carne de un dólar o
dormíamos en alfombras o en colchones
inflables estábamos bien
nos sentíamos bien no había crisis
alguna realmente estábamos cumpliendo el
sueño de cualquier emprendedor tec
nuestro paso por nuestro paso por san
francisco nos aseguran inversión en
chile de hecho en una reunión con los
socios decidimos que yo yo sería quien
iría a representar la empresa ya y cómo
es la vida un tiempo después de esta
primera crisis de colegio hacía mis
maletas y empezaba mi nueva vida en
santiago
en chile quizás fue uno de los momentos
en que más trabaje en mi vida como
empresa teníamos una gran oportunidad no
nos inversión y todo lo que los
emprendedores buscamos como emprendedor
estaba en el lugar donde sucedían las
cosas realmente me sentí en la cima no
me podía perder nada
pero en medio de todo este trajín e
intensidad en medio de todas estas
charlas con inversionistas y con
emprendedores y despertarse desvelarse
noches y noches pensando cómo hacerla la
idea del millón muchas veces demasiado
exagerada previo algo empezó a cambiar
algo estaba mal y es que esas ganas de
inspiración con la que habíamos
comenzado muchísimo tiempo atrás cuando
empezamos a hacer cinturones ya no están
más
inclusive cosas tan triviales como el
dinero no me consolaba y de hecho si yo
les muestro y les comparó mi vida de ese
punto cuando era emprendedor sin un peso
podrían darse cuenta que mis momentos de
inspiración eran eran inversamente
proporcionales a la cantidad de dólares
que en el banco
y esto me sirvió para darme cuenta que
había encendido una mecha muchísimo
mayor hace algún tiempo atrás y estaba a
punto de explotar
y explotó
explotó porque yo sentía y es yo sabía
que mi pasión y mi porque era emprender
pero en ese aumento el producto como
emprendedor no iba de la mano con él
porque como persona y que ahí y que hay
muy fuerte
y tan fuerte que me en corte la peor
crisis intelectual emocional espiritual
e inclusive
espiritual de mi vida
había dejado la empresa que me había
tomado mucho los últimos cuatro años en
construir la había dejado porque no
sentía que no tienen por qué porque
claro para sumar problemas la mujer con
la que quería estar ya no quería estar
conmigo porque pensaba que había perdido
mi rumbo hace mucho tiempo atrás siendo
un emprendedor no tenía ahorros no
tenían sueldos no tenía beneficios los
pocos ahorros que tenía de hechos o
están invertidos en la empresa que acaba
de dejar o se me acaba viviendo en un
país es bastante caro en ese momento
para mí que era chile el aquel de
cementos impagable y si bien siempre
supe que puede contar con el apoyo de mi
familia sentía que tenía que vivir esta
crisis sólo recuerdo que un tiempo
después como no podía pagar el alquiler
seguramente no sabe mi madre
pero tuve que ir a vivir al sillón de un
amigo un gran sillón de un amigo tal
cual
un gran amigo que me abrió las puertas
de su casa para darme un techo un sillón
claramente pero también para intentar
darme de energía que necesitaba para
sentirme inspirado y crear de nuevo
en ese momento en mi mente en intocable
y me llovían recuerdos de dolor de
ansiedades de malestares y de crisis que
había decidido parchar
muchas de esas noches desembocaban en
depresión ira y sentimientos realmente
que no tenía que no había sentido nunca
me encantas en mi vida muchas de esas
noches desembocaban en llantos en
lágrimas y en una que otra visita al bar
pero en medio de todo esta tormenta y
todo esto existe en grande algo dentro
de mí se sintió realmente cansado de
esta situación y me di cuenta que la
única manera de salir de esta situación
que se apoderaba de mí y era parte de mi
vida duro intentando rechazar tapar y
esconder lo que sabía que dentro de mí
era verdad
sentía que si quería cambiar y hacer
realmente cambios en mi vida estos
cambios deberían ser transversales ya
que si solamente me dedicaba a cambiar
algunas partes que me incomodaban mi
rutina y la forma en la que había
acostumbrado a vivir me arrastraría a la
misma mujer
fue en ese momento cuando decidí aceptar
abrazar y agradecer la crisis y lo digo
de nuevo decidí aceptar abrazar y
agradecer la crisis y en ese momento fue
lo que has mágico porque dentro de mí de
dentro de mi cabeza en mi cuerpo y mi
alma despertar un millón de nuevas
sensaciones que tenían sabor oportunidad
y recuerdo qué
en este punto y va y va y un viaje en
bus a visitar a un amigo en viña y
pasaron este vídeo que seguramente lo
conocen se los quiero compartir
yo canté playas 1er
en primer lugar
[Música]
como youtube al frío
kuwait
ah
y ya está
bueno hablar
arriba
hola
por cristóbal
[Música]
and i'm in your boots' maría lanau
por aquí
[Música]
reid
[Aplausos]
y en ese momento me di cuenta que no
estaba dispuesto a sacrificar mi mayor
anhelo que era la libertad por no
animarme a luchar más batallas con las
crisis después de todo no eran guerras
tan duras
y es que o moría ese día intentando lo
que quería hacer viviría el resto mi
vida queriendo volver ese día cuando
decidí no hacerlo
hoy después de cinco años construimos
nuestra tercera empresa ladrillo a
ladrillo y estamos en el rubro donde
conectamos a las personas con la
tecnología para crear mejores ciudades y
ciudades más seguras nos encantan
y lo que más aprendí de toda esta
tormenta y toda esta crisis que casi me
deja realmente en el piso fueron tres
cosas uno que no estamos solos en esos
momentos cuando sentimos solos y vacíos
si solamente decidimos ver un poco más
allá de esa burbuja gris nos damos
cuenta que tenemos a alguien una persona
un amigo por último un extraño que está
dispuesta a darnos una mano un empujón o
por lo menos una cerveza la segunda cosa
que aprendí es que el dinero nos
proporciona la felicidad que si está
bueno crear empresas y de hecho por eso
hacemos las empresas porque queremos
éxito financiero pero es mucho más
gratificante si cada dólar viene
acompañado con esfuerzo con pasión y con
impacto
y tres que las crisis creces y que si
nos dedicamos a tapar enterrar rechazar
o postergar lo que dentro de nosotros
sabemos que es verdad entonces estoy
seguro que ese conflicto los percibirá
por el resto subía hasta que decían
afrontarlos
y ver y hacerle crecer de y es que todos
conocen la metáfora del elefante en el
cuarto verdad para los que no imagínense
que acá en todo este cuarto es un
elefante gigante que solamente ustedes
lo pueden ver y que ese elefante está
cargado de todos sus miedos e
inseguridades sueños frustrados y todo
lo que los temores a ese se le falta en
el cuarto entre los invito a que se den
cuenta de cuál es ese elefante nerd
cuarto es el quizás el trabajo que gana
los hace felices o la persona o su
pareja que ya no aman más o quizás la
enfermedad que saben que tienen que no
la querían aceptar cuando antes hagan
las paces con el tamaño de se levanten y
decidan afrontar y así y abrazar y
agradecer esas crisis antes podrán sacar
algo de ellas
y les hablo de películas así que quiero
ser william wallace y de estas analogías
de la vida porque siempre me gustó
pensar en mi vida
como con diferentes
analogías y metáforas por ejemplo de la
película o de pensar que estuvo una
pelea de box donde todo es fuerza y
resistencia donde tengo que entrenar
muchísimo pero tampoco me hace feliz o
me hacía feliz pensar que mi vida sean
durísimos 12 durísimos rounds con
demasiados golpes en la cara
quizás la analogía y con esto ya lo voy
terminando quizás la analogía que hoy me
da más paz es la de pensar que estoy
pintando una obra de arte y si en toda
la presentación vieron estos puntos
quizás incomprensibles de manera
individual para mí son momentos que
marcaron mi vida inflexiones grandes o
pequeñas decisiones de decidir o de
continuar de girar o de avanzar
puntos marcados con trazos colores
y cosas y pinturas tonos y cosas que van
armando y que van dibujando algo que
cuando yo voy viéndolo desde lejos va
dibujando algo que funciona y es aquí
donde les pregunto qué es una crisis
para ustedes porque para mí en realidad
una crisis no es nada más que una
reacción de nuestro cuerpo de nuestra
cabeza de nuestro corazón o de nuestro
entorno al hecho de dejar de construir y
crear algo porque sinceramente pienso
que no hay mayor desperdicio de vida que
vivir o más bien sobrevivir sin crear o
construir algo ya sea una empresa una
pintura una canción o una familia
entonces los invito a permitirse a tener
crisis porque pienso que la gente no se
permiten a la crisis y permitan se tener
crisis y conectarse con ella sienta las
vivan las con el objetivo de crear
puntos trazos y pinceladas y colores
para que al final del día cuando ustedes
empiecen a ver su vida quizás de un poco
más lejos quizás de muchos de ustedes en
el pliego de su existencia habrán
construido una obra de alto y solo
y que solamente depende de ustedes hacer
que esa obra de arte sea única
trascendental y digna del ser colgado en
algún museo gracias
[Aplausos]